I received my model of clear hist and clear CV today and see that they both been reformulated.
Can you tell me about the changes and why they were done?
So the clear CV, we wanted to add vitamin A to it because the synergistic effects of
those things for clear CV to help with with colds and viruses, it was just missing vitamin
A. So we switched it to add vitamin A.
So that's really the only difference of clear CV.
The clear hist formula is a little bit different because we just went to, we switched to a
different company with that that I was happier with the total product itself.
So the clear hist there's more, it's a similar product but there's more changes to it.
I just think it's a much better product or always just searching to give you the best products
and especially products that have our names on it, we want the best product out there.